[Narrator] "Midsommar" is a horror movie
about a Swedish festival
gone very, very wrong.
The film was written and
directed by Ari Aster,
the man behind 2018's "Hereditary."
This follow-up is equally
disturbing and just as baffling.
Here are all of the symbols
and hidden references
in the movie, and how they
relate to its shocking ending.
Warning: Spoilers ahead.
First of all, while "Midsommar"
quickly turns into a cultish nightmare,
the movie is ultimately about
the end of a relationship
between the two main
characters, Dani and Christian.
Ari Aster was recovering
from a breakup of his own
while he was developing the film,
and that experience influenced
his writing of the characters,
in particular Dani.
He was also inspired by romantic films,
like 1973's "Scenes From a Marriage"
and 1981's "Modern Romance."
Robert: I don't think that
we should go out anymore.
[Narrator] As for his horror influences,
there's a clear reference to "The Shining"
in this overhead shot of the journey.
Early in the movie, the
paintings on the walls
of the apartments hint
toward the ending of the film
and the very messy breakup we witness.
In Christian's apartment,
we see a painting
by Brooklyn-based artist Mu Pan.
The work is part of a series
called "Dinoassholes,"
a title that seems very appropriate
for Christian's character,
given his callous treatment of Dani.
Also visible is this work by
Swedish artist John Bauer.
It depicts a little girl in
a crown facing a large bear.
This painting directly
alludes to the movie's ending,
when Christian is placed
inside a bear carcass
and set on fire.
Dani watches him burn while
wearing a crown of flowers.
Later, in Siv's house,
Christian also sees an image on the wall
of a bear being burned alive,
further foreshadowing his untimely death.
Simon: So we're just going
to ignore the bear then?
Ingemar: It's a bear.
[Narrator] Aster compared
the sacrificial burning of the temple
to the burning of a box
of an ex's personal items
as a sort of catharsis post-breakup,
only, of course, far more extreme.
The sacrificial burning at the end
also calls back the ending
of "The Wicker Man,"
in which the outsider main character
is placed in a wooden
statue and set afire.
Aster and his team spent months
researching Scandinavian
and Germanic folklore
and scattered Easter
eggs throughout the film,
which also hint at the culmination
of Dani and Christian's relationship,
major plot points,
and other characters' deaths.
One of the most important
set pieces, the bunkhouse,
exemplifies this attention to detail.
The inner walls are
covered in elaborate murals
painted by artist Ragnar Persson
and based on medieval art.
If you look closely,
these images actually
reveal much of the plot.
Basically, the bunkhouse
fulfills the same function
as the dollhouse did in "Hereditary,"
illustrating much of the story
before it actually happens.
For example, above one of the beds
we see an illustration
of two people having sex,
surrounded by onlookers.
This clearly refers to the mating ritual
Christian is later lured
into to impregnate Maja.
This scene is also hinted at
when the boys are eating
earlier in the film
and discussing all of the Swedish girls
they plan on impregnating during the trip.
Another illustration shows people
cutting their hands as a sacrifice.
Soon after, we see the
old couple cut their palms
atop the cliff, right before
they jump to their deaths.
Also covering the walls are many runes,
an ancient language that features heavily
throughout the film.
At one point, the characters
refer to the runes
as Elder Futhark
and Younger Futhark,
two evolutions of the
same system of language.
Looking at the meanings
of some of these symbols,
we can try to piece together
why Aster chose them
in certain parts of the movie.
He assigned each character a rune,
which we can see clearly on their robes.
Dani has an R rune on her dress,
which symbolizes a ride or a journey.
This likely refers to her
own journey of finally
coming to terms with the
truth about her relationship.
The hourglass-shaped rune next it
symbolizes day or an awakening.
This likely refers to Dani's
breakthrough about Christian,
a moment of clarity for her.
Dani's character also
experiences a slow reawakening
throughout the festival.
The first sign of her rebirth
is when she wakes up from her nap
and suddenly her skin appears
golden and almost glittery.
Meanwhile, Christian's
robe has an up-arrow rune,
which could reference
either the male symbol
or a willingness to self-sacrifice,
ironically, a quality he does not have.
The first bloody sacrifice we witness
is that of two senior
members of the community
who throw themselves off a cliff.
This tradition is called ättestupa.
It's based off of Nordic
legends in which people
would commit ritual suicide
when they grew too old to care
for themselves any longer.
When the man and woman
rub their bloody hands
on the rune stones,
the two symbols that appear
are the R from Dani's robe
and the up arrow from Christian's robe.
The shape of the dining
table is also significant.
This rune symbolizes tradition,
the passing down of rituals and rites.
If you look closely at the
sunlike entrance to the village,
you'll see the same
shape, but upside-down.
The X inside the sacred
temple can mean gift,
which makes sense, as
the community is planning
on gifting nine souls to the gods.
Beyond the bunkhouse murals,
there's a tapestry in the open field
that also foretells parts of the plot.
It depicts a bizarre love story
in which a girl puts her
menstrual blood and pubic hair
in a boy's food and drink to
make him fall in love with her.
This is exactly what
Maja does to Christian.
You can see here that his drink
is darker than the others,
with a reddish tint.
And he pulls a pubic hair out of his mouth
after taking a bite of the pie.
While the most horrific events
in the film are fictitious,
the holiday and many of
its rituals are very real.
Midsummer is an annual event
that takes place in mid-June,
around the summer solstice.
It's popular across the globe,
particularly in Scandinavia.
And it's even depicted briefly
in the Disney movie "Frozen."
Midsummer was initially a pagan holiday,
but it eventually merged
with the Christian feast day
of St. John the Baptist,
a celebration of the prophet's birth.
Indeed, there are several
references to John the Baptist
in the film.
Pelle tells Dani that the
festival lasts nine days
and that the event is special because
it only occurs every 90 years.
In the Bible, the Virgin Mary stayed with
John the Baptist's mother, Elizabeth,
for 90 days before Elizabeth gave birth.
Then, when they get to the
field outside the village,
Ingemar wishes Pelle a
happy St. John's in Swedish.
One of the flowers that covers the village
is St. John's wort.
It's customary to celebrate
St. John's Day with bonfires,
like the one that burned
the sacrifices alive
in the final scene,
and with torches, like those
that the villagers carry
throughout the film.
One of the key components of
"Midsommar" is the maypole,
which we see in the film
covered in flowers and greenery
for good luck.
The ritual in which the villagers
dance around the maypole
is based in a real-life Midsummer custom,
one that revolves around
procreation and fertility.
So it makes sense that
Christian's bizarre sex ritual
is a major part of what comes next.
The community makes way for new life
by making a lot of bloody sacrifices.
Let's start with what happened to Josh.
When he goes to bed on his last night,
he's already set on sneaking into the barn
to photograph the holy book.
The camera lingers on his shoes
as he pulls the blanket over his body.
The shot of his sneakers
may be referencing
the mass suicide of the
Heaven's Gate cult in 1997,
when 39 cult members were
found dead on their bunk beds,
having taken a powerful sedative
and covered themselves in purple sheets.
As an anthropology student,
Josh is obsessed with northern
European pagan traditions,
to the extent where he's fully
embraced this cult in Sweden.
His ambition and academic passion
is ultimately what brings his demise.
In the barn, Josh is attacked by Ulf,
the same man who got angry at Mark
for peeing on the ancestral tree.
The most disturbing part: Ulf
is now wearing Mark's face.
Later, we see the skin of Mark's face
placed on a straw dummy and
topped off with a jester's hat.
This cruel fate is foreshadowed
earlier in the movie.
Simon: What are they playing?
Ingemar: Skin the Fool.
[Narrator] In retrospect,
this bit of foreshadowing
makes sense, as Mark pretty neatly fit
the comedic archetype of the fool.
An even greater horror is done to Simon,
the Londoner who mysteriously disappeared
without his fiancée, Connie.
Christian stumbles on Simon
tied face-down in the chicken coop,
with his back sliced open
and liver and ribs exposed.
As we look closer, we see
that his lungs are moving,
indicating that Simon is still alive.
If you're wondering how anyone
could come up with this stuff,
it turns out Aster did months of research
on Viking torture techniques.
What Simon's subjected to is right in line
with the "blood eagle" method
of execution by torture,
a prolonged type of ritual killing
detailed in Norse poetry.
So why have such brutal Viking rituals
survived in this insular community?
And what does it all mean?
To get an idea, we should look to Ruben,
the so-called oracle in the community.
As an elder in the village explains,
Ruben was purposely inbred
to serve as a conduit
for the word of the gods.
The boy is said to have unclouded judgment
as a result of his condition
and his pure blood.
Towards the end of the movie,
he's shown sitting on a
seat covered in cotton,
looking almost like
he's sitting on a cloud.
In Aster's words, Ruben embodies
the political message of the film,
which is perhaps partly
critiquing the global rise
of xenophobia and the return
of the far right in Sweden.
As Aster said in an interview,
"If you consider Swedish history,
it is a very closed society.
And what does that really mean?
There are things happening
in Sweden right now
that are echoes of things that happened
in the Second World War."
OK, now back to the ending of the film.
It seems that the burning
of the sacred temple
was part of Pelle's plan
from the very beginning.
One theory: While Dani's family seemed
to die in a murder-suicide,
what if it was actually a setup?
Next to her parents' bed
was a crown of flowers,
and there are similar yellow flowers
on their wallpaper too,
a mysterious bit of foreshadowing.
What if, say, Pelle killed Dani's family
to trigger the series of events
that led her to the festival?
He does emphasize that he
was most looking forward
to Dani coming along on the
trip, more than anyone else.
Whether or not Dani was chosen by Pelle,
there are some other
hints that she was always
a perfect candidate for May Queen.
One is her birthday,
which Pelle is well aware
coincides with the
beginning of the festival.
Dani's in her mid-20s, which
is significant because,
as Pelle explains,
his community thinks of one's
life in terms of seasons.
The first 16 years of life
are equivalent to one season,
spring.
Dani is midway through
the next season, summer,
so literally midsummer.
Regardless of the impetus
for Dani's journey,
the movie comes full
tragic circle by the end,
beginning with the deaths of her family
and ending with the death of Christian.
As Aster says, "You start
with the unfathomable,
and you end with the unfathomable."
So did we miss anything?
Let us know in the comments.